clear
from the officer's response that they
absolutely save people's lives this is a
tragic event but it was it was the
heroic response of officers that made
sure that no more people were more
seriously injured than what happened we
will continue to provide updates as soon
as possible we will have another press
briefing following this at 3 pm today I
will turn it over to Mayor Craig
Greenberg at this time
thank you deputy chief Humphrey
first I asked that
everyone around our city around the
country around the world
pray with us for
those who are currently at uofl hospital
injured
fighting for their lives as a result
of another
Act of gun violence
and I want to thank
all of the First Responders the Brave
and heroic
men and women of lmpd
who thanks to their efforts
quickly responded to the emergency call
and as you just heard from deputy chief
Humphrey without a doubt their actions
saved lives
there will be a lot more information we
are able to provide as the day goes on
but I want everyone in the city to know
that notwithstanding
tragedies like today
when multiple people
are killed by gun violence
notwithstanding tragedies when
individuals are killed by gun violence
our community will continue to come
together
we will find ways to love and support
one another and the families and friends
who have been directly impacted
by these acts of gun violence
and we will come together as a community
to work to prevent
these horrific Acts
of gun violence from continuing
here and around the state
I want to thank again everyone at lmpd
from the Louisville fire department from
EMS
from the state agencies and now federal
agencies that are also involved
we are a safer Community we are a
stronger community
thanks to the work of our law
enforcement
and again
my prayers go out to the families
who have lost loved ones today
my prayers go out to the officers who
are at the hospital right now
and my thanks for all of them
through with together we will get
through this together
finally I want to introduce governor
beshear
who has joined us and who is assisting
with the efforts governor
I want to start by thanking the brave
heroes in lmpd and our other responding
organizations lmpd made it to this scene
in a matter of minutes after receiving
the call and there is no doubt in my
mind that their efforts saved lives and
they put their own on the line and we
have at least one officer in surgery
right now that is there because he took
those actions to try to protect the
people of Louisville I want to thank
Louisville fire Louisville Metro EMS and
Emergency Management in the Louisville
Sheriff's Office for the immediate
response they've now been joined by the
FBI ATF Homeland Security Kentucky State
Police have requested in the Louisville
office of safe and healthy neighborhoods
in this response
this is awful
I have a very close friend that didn't
make it today
and I have another close friend who
didn't either and one who's at the
hospital
that I hope is is going to make it
through
so when we talk about praying I hope
people will
for those that we
are hoping can make it through the
surgeries that they're going through
and then we've got to do what we have
done these last three years after
everything we've got to wrap our arms
around these families
and everybody who needs it don't be
afraid to get some help
our bodies and our minds are not meant
to go through these types of tragedies
and so I hope that all the brave
officers that stepped into the line of
fire that are worried about one of their
fellow officers we'll reach out for help
when they need it I hope every one of
those Bank employees and folks in that
building one that I know well
and My AG campaign was out of that
building
I know virtually everyone in it that's
my bank
I hope that they will all reach out and
get the help that they need there are a
lot of people that are hurting today
and if we have a place to focus our
energy I hope it is to surround them
with the love
and the compassion that we have been so
good at showing one another
I want people to know that while today
is a horrific act I do believe that this
is a safe Community with officers doing
their very best each and every day and
that's what we saw here yes I know that
there are steps that the police
department is taking to do things better
after a recent report but we certainly
saw I think the very best from them
today
and I want to thank them and all our
other law enforcement officers
corresponding and doing their best
to try to save some of my friends and
many others thank you all
any questions
uh the other one it appears to be uh
non-critical injuries at this time
of the time I'm not sure on the status
of that yet they'll be part of the
investigation
excuse me
it appears the shooter was I don't know
if it was an active employee or a former
employee but the shooter did have a
connection to the to the location
no
don't know that
he asked was there any formal security
at the bank we don't know that either
that'll be part of the investigation so
one more
we we have resources available to make
sure the rest of the city is kept safe
and I do want to reiterate that we are
managing our Resources with the state
local and federal Partners to make sure
that all services to the city maintain
while we are maintaining the scene at
the same time so thank you the next
update will be at three o'clock
thank you